we have some similarities in that we
both uh well not just coming from
Massachusetts but I think we have
certain P similar
personalities um uh in in terms of kinds
of things that we find funny and oh yes
but old timey speak we love old timey
speak that was the big thing from the
from the abbreviating the state show
because that I used the word n do well
and I live in Harlem and I never thought
I would get recognized in Harlem because
I'm one of the few white Jewish men who
live up there and and a saw me on the
street last month and this I mean that
thing came out seven or eight years ago
right and the man saw me and he yelled n
do
well isn't that great though it was the
greatest thing that ever I don't get
recognized very much in general but when
I do oh man does it feel good it's
probably irritating at your level but at
my level it's still like a oh I don't
ever I'm not irritated I great I like uh
and and you say oh I'd be irritated by
questions I'm not I just like I I like
talking to people uh almost uh and and
Sona will is often with me when I'm out
in the world and and bla is too but
often people will start chatting with me
and I'll keep chatting with them and
then they say I have to go oh my
go I I'll go with you talk more about
comedy I do these meet and greets after
the after the show and sometimes I'll
I'll connect with the people and and
it's like I have to go back to a hotel
room and be by
myself yeah it's like turning back into
Bill Bixby after being the incredible
hul that feeling you've talked about as
I can kind of relate to this you have
kind of an OCD about honesty oh and and
I I had this too growing up which is
there's a lot of um uh it was very
important to my mom that we all be
thought of well yeah and uh I love my
mom and she's just super she's superum
person who who did so much when we were
growing up to keep this madness together
and uh and I idolize her at the same
time she she always wanted uh people
when people came over she would put on a
little bit of a well yes now come here
she' become because she wanted everyone
to think that that you know we're not
low class Irish we are we are lace
curtain Irish and it was a whole thing
but she would say things and we would
all notice like what happened to
Mom and it was important and I
remembered it was always very important
to me and I think it's one of the
reasons I got into comedy I always had
to say nope that's not true oh my gosh
that's not and one of the things my
mother would give me the stare yeah I
get that too yeah and she would one of
the things I remembered is we'd all be
gathered around you know Christmas
Thanksgiving and we have company
over uh or anytime company was coming
and we got to sit in the in the in the
dining room and people are sitting
around she'd say and now of course we
always say grace and I'd say we only do
this when company's here oh no and she
would say that's not true oh that's so
good but I mean I I just couldn't not I
had to always say that's not true yeah
that yeah the dishonesty part of it is
is I grew up always feeling God was
watching me all the time just because of
the the I just took everything everybody
told me seriously so that I would act up
in the house I would stub my toe on on
the corner of a of a counter and and my
that doesn't make sense not a counter a
cabinet and and my mother would say see
God punished you oh and I was like oh my
gosh instead of thinking gosh what a
prick I I would I would think oh I
better not act think I used to think
doesn't God have other things to
do hey Gman just got out of line give
the Old ST
hey what about that what about that
tsunami that just wiped out 3,000 people
in Indonesia oh I was dealing with
Gman and then I I went to Hebrew school
I don't know if you went to Catholic I
went to Hebrew school yeah I was
immediately asked to leave no I went to
Catholic instruction actually with Brian
Kylie oh that's so interesting I so I I
would go to Hebrew school and they would
say well this is a sin adultery and
coveting being jealous and and bearing
false witness and uh are there any
others uh yes leaving the finger paints
out is that is that also a sin that God
that God will Smite you for um but
playing with clay without permission
that's that's another one that God
punished me
for yeah it it was just the the the
things I was learning in Hebrew school
were not matching up with with the
little I had learned at home is there am
I correct that there's probably really
not much difference between if you're a
kid Hebrew instruction and if you're a
kid Catholic instruction meaning they're
both leaning on guilt beware watch out
someone's watching because that was my
experience and then uh the few times
that well actually I grew up in Brooklyn
um more of my friends were Jewish than
were Irish Catholics sure and I would
sense that wait a minute this is
supposed to be a completely alien
religion this is all sounding pretty
familiar to me totally and these people
are really funny yes so there's some
there's all this like transference yeah
and and and also the presentation is
very similar the ornate the rituals the
the the just the the churches are
gorgeous and and many of these
synagogues especially the older ones are
are so so impressive in terms of
architecture and the stained glass and
everything like that it's very very
interesting but I always I went to a
Catholic College I went to Boston
College and I befriended some jzu
priests and they would say yeah there's
a lot of intersection in our in our um
in our liturgy not so much much the
words as much as the the ideas and the
and the um where the stresses are which
is on a a very angry judgmental
God and but but but as a lot of fathers
do when they have a son late in life
they mellow and that and that and that's
where I see protestantism is sort of a
mellow of God not as yeah not as likely
to Smite after having
Jesus yeah the Protestants have a he's
it's a God that's like we're
loafers and
Dockers and he's it's Pete Holmes yeah
it's Pete Holmes it's Pete Holmes's God
as opposed to like Bill Burr is the
Catholic God where I like I like
figuring out religion just using
standups oh my gosh specifically
specifically Northeastern standups you
know what I mean so I'm now I'm trying
to figure out who would be the Jewish
comedian God it would it wouldn't it
wouldn't be Crystal it wouldn't be
no too light Lewis Black I just got it
it's LS black because he' be saying
things like do I get this straight let
me understand something you a post
office wants me to spend money on a
stamp and then I spend money on the St
you know that kind of thing wow that's
good you know what I used to do the
morens and the sodomites are having
you know what I used to
do I used to do a louw I like Lew us but
I used to do a Louis black impression
where he's getting because his whole
thing was getting worked up over
something that's kind of small and I
used to do a Lewis Black impression
about things where it's where he's
worked up about something you should be
worked up about so i' be like have you
heard about this thing called
kidnapping someone takes a child they
take they take a child who is the only
son or daughter of these loving parents
and they they take them away and they
say you'll only see them alive again if
we get
money and it would really make me laugh
cuz I'd be like uhhuh yeah just him
getting mad about stuff he should get
mad about it this Kylie used to always
tell me he would say you have no idea
how funny the meetings are in in Conan's
office and and initially I was skeptical
I I thought um you said Conan's not that
funny how no I said yeah everybody's
going to laugh at their
right and and then I started listening
to the to the podcast but also he would
tell me the stories the the bits you
would do which was one of my favorites
was the dirty Brian Kylie the Kylie yeah
I would do Brian it's called Brian Kylie
at the
Apollo now Brian Kylie again as you know
yeah tells really clean jokes and he
wears creased chinos and a and a blue
and schless puts no nothing on it the
jokes are just I mean I'm they're
perfect you could read them they're
beautiful but also his
character man but Kylie and he'd stand
up there and he's very Catholic and he
tells these wonderful jokes and he
always is doing this with his hands he
doesn't move his body really at all when
he's up on stage and so I started doing
Kylie at the Pao where he's up there and
he's like uh hi everybody uh good to see
you I'm Brian Kylie and uh the other day
I'm uh I'm going down on this uh going
down on this
and I'm uh so I'm eating I'm
eating her
out and then and he's still the same
mannerism and then I uh I work my way
you know down to her uh to her
you know and I start uh start licking
out her oh God and then I'm like
you've got to wash your ass and
he's killing murdering but then he goes
backstage kills and he goes well that's
my time thank you and then he goes
backstage and I would always have him
sit in a little iron chair and read a
Truman biography quietly and then
someone would come and go get out there
again they want more of you he'd be like
oh okay and he Clos it and he'd go back
out there and go uh the other day I'm uh
I'm whipping this guy with a like
whatever it's just F it's weird to hear
you even talk like that I know I know
but the thing is when I'm channeling
Kylie so in meetings I would just do
these bits that had nothing to do what
was going to be nothing the whole rule
was none of this helps the show none of
this can be on the show none of it can
help the show we and I would do these
long and especially in the post show
meeting if a guest hadn't been good or
if a bit hadn't worked I could do 40
minutes destroying and and uh it was
really fun I I that's the thing I missed
the thing I missed the most he said were
there were four or five shows the day of
the show I would do shows before the and
then the show was like oh we got to go
do that show huh the one that people see
well that's no fun I want to do Kylie at
the
Apollo you've got to wash your ass so F
and he's looking side to side and he's
got he's doing this with his because you
got to see Brian Brian KY is a great
comic but just the idea that he would do
any joke like this it's just right it's
just insane yes it's just funnier cuz I
know who Brian Kylie is and I I hope
people go and like look at his comedy
online look at Brian kyli how much of a
just how different it is that what
you're saying I took a the other
day and you know when you take a
and then at the same
time you know and then it's just like it
gets like incredibly insane I would and
and and and when I would Channel this
stuff I would be saying stuff that I
don't even think about but suddenly it's
coming out because I'm doing Kylie at
the Apollo which love it so much joy uh
oh BL what's the
matter I hate all of this why I mean
it's I I love it but imagining Kylie do
it it's it's just it's crazy because he
is the most I think he might be the most
straight laac person I've ever met in my
life and just now I have the mental
image of him doing also you know what I
always do I'd always add him driving
home in a very small sensible Square car
yeah and just you know and then going
home and pulling the blanket up to his
chin to go to sleep and then the phone
rings with a night cap with a night cap
and then and then the phone rings and
it's the club going they're screaming
for you they want more and so he gets
out puts on his Blazer gets back in his
little car goes back there and then goes
out and becomes this other person yeah I
picture him with a pipe Carousel yeah
pipes and then and the other thing is
that I
he's the person who reads the most long
books like Robert Carol those LBJ books
the person one of the people yeah he and
I have that same Affliction oh I didn't
realize that I was G to that was one of
the questions I was going to ask you
what is your are you a big reader yeah I
well I read a ton of history and uh and
Kylie was the same thing but we were
always both like Kylie and I are just
very similar and that we're these two I
see Irish Catholic guys from Boston who
if you see a picture of us on a beach
everyone else is in a thong and playing
pickle ball we're the ones reading books
that weigh about 80 lbs and they have a
swastika on the cover cuz it's
about world the rise the rise and fall
of the the rise and fall of the Third
Reich yeah oh my gosh annotated
annotated yeah and we're like picking
out things that are wrong wow you just
went up in my book of people who read
books okay well good yeah um I'd like to
think did you like that Robert Kyro
documentary have you seen that that I'm
in it oh yes you I'm sorry I got
I got confused because you were also in
the uh you thought that was Dennis you
thought that was Dennis liry going on
and on about Carol the Larry uh the Gary
Shandling documentary yeah these days
everyone's in every documentary yeah and
I I yeah I'm in documentaries I
shouldn't be in about like sex
trafficking in
Sweden and they just and con Brian you
should be in that one now I was
cleared